what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story
today we got more joy boy hype and we
finally got a confirmed conclusion to
the law and kid versus big mom fight we
get to see her fate so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy seeing
these one-piece reviews on the channel
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do chill the pirate king within
and smash that like button always
remember smashing that like button is
pyroking energy and passing is scared
orochi energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one piece videos and updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my big one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all yonko warlord supernova and much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
its spoilers and all this chapter is
called falling on deaf ears and man does
it work perfectly for this chapter as
we're about to find out so as we saw
last chapter kid released his very
strong cannon and i thought it was over
because of how long we've been covering
it how long we've been in wano and how
we need to get to luffy and kaido
eventually and it was close to being
over but oda uses a portion of this
chapter to wrap it up paying even more
respect to yonko being defeated which
after how much yonko have been built up
makes total sense now it's even harder
to complain that ayanka was beat too
easily kid's attack is pushing big mom
into a hole that reaches all the way
through the floating island and even
well below the ground way below however
big mom is not falling through it she's
a boss as usual and even says that when
kids attack stops tickling her the two
can either give her 50 years from their
lifespans or they can live as her slaves
she starts stealing the lifespans of the
people around and the surrounding people
comment on how she's a monster who
doesn't look anywhere near death's door
aka she's got a pretty good poker face
law subordinates are freaking out and
say they've gotta get out of here but
law is super cool as usual and says you
guys go ahead kid says the last gasps of
an old wind bag don't scare him and law
activates room while commenting on big
mom's death screeches so the two aren't
frightened and thus big mom cannot
actually take their souls in this manner
it's even pointed out with surprise that
their souls aren't coming out and
they're praised that she's an emperor
and they're not scared at all lying
references corazon when he says i'll
handle this just like the man who saved
my life who of course used his power so
that law's cries wouldn't be heard while
he was escaping kid is just unrelenting
and blunt as usual saying he'll send the
emperor to the afterlife and despite big
mom's talk to kids credit she really
appears to be paralyzed by the canon
attack since she can't move while law is
preparing his own thing with roon law
creates a bubble around big mom and
cancels out every sound she's making
it's funny how law even teases her
pretty much saying oh what's that i
can't hear you
then kid says have another and increases
the power of his continuous attack kind
of like a continued kamehameha and then
like just another push i guess you could
say of it this sends big mom further and
further down into the hole and she has
the so hurt her eyes or whited out thing
going on she wants prometheus and hera
to save her but she can't actually give
orders and say anything eventually she
breaks through to yamato's level and to
yamato's shock because so much damage
made no sound big mom is conscious now
but realizes that nothing she touches
makes a sound she sets off some bombs
but yamato with her ice powers keeps the
damage contained as we knew she would
and the next thing we know big mom is
even more beat up from the explosions
coughing out smoke she's already passed
through the entire floating island
meaning kid in law have done their job
her internal dialogue is interesting as
well she actually calls out roger the
pirate king himself asking why did he
have to go and say all that stuff the
whole world bought it the great pirate
era thing big mom is upset because his
time was up so it didn't affect him but
it does affect her and all those brats
came flooding in looking for their
chance to shine and roger left them
meaning that generation or the uncle to
deal with it while she's thinking this
we also see robin and brooke running
apparently towards zoro's collapsed body
we know zoro is eventually going to be
okay but right now this is insane damage
even for zoro's high pain threshold it
would be funny if the death figure he
saw was just a hallucination combined
with brook's image coming to save him
here but if anyone is close enough to
death right now to actually see death
it's gotta be zorro back to big mom and
she has this interesting camaraderie
with roger like a friend who feels she
was owed more and should have been
treated better she thinks that roger
could have at least told them or their
generation about the one piece before he
croaked and i really loved this feeling
of pirate camaraderie among the legends
and the strongest pirates we also see
rhizo still in the thick of all that
fire and he's the one standing as his
opponent is on the ground saying he
needs water and so rhizo in a very cool
and stoic way came up with the win here
in naruto a ninja is referred to by
kakashi as one who endures so this fight
was pretty much perfect for these two
ninja and ryzel definitely did a great
job at being a ninja aka he did a great
job at enduring big mom is approaching
ground level now in the circular silent
room wondering what is the one piece
where is it does wano hold some of the
answers she's so frustrated by it all
she thinks about kid in-law and how she
won't forgive this she tells them this
won't be enough to kill her and i don't
think anyone really expected them to
kill her just to temporarily beat her or
get her out of the way and she looks
scared as finally another giant
explosion engulfs her we're told in
black and white terms this time no need
to speculate the victors are says the
narrator eustis captain kid and the
surgeon of death trafalgar law the great
thing is too because of the silent room
the giant explosion is not even heard by
the partying capital nearby kit and law
are really drained now and you can see
it it took a lot out of them to smash
big mom like that their side celebrates
saying they defeated big mom this is
huge really huge and i can't agree with
that statement more it's happened we've
defeated ionko and even if big mom
returns to her crew you know the
newspapers will make a big deal of this
defeat and she won't be looked at the
same way again kind of sucks for her
though since she got double teamed and
didn't have the help of her crew here
like kaido did to help her out we then
jump back to yamato who sees momo
through the hole in the basement she
explains one of the bombs went off but
she was able to freeze the others before
the whole armory blew solid job by
yamato here momo then tells her
something else that's huge zunisha is
getting pretty close now yamato responds
you mean the elephant odin mentioned in
his journal and momo says yes exactly it
committed a serious crime 800 years ago
back when it was joyboy's companion and
that's when the chapter ends and we are
told we are going to be on a break next
week more joy boy stuff this arc has
been really amazing for that it was
before suggested by miyagi that zunisha
may not be walking around aimlessly as
it was sentenced to but may actually be
looking for a certain location and now
that we know that zunisha was friends
with joyboy it could be it is looking
for a certain person rather than
location aka could be looking for the
next joyboy and the fact that it's
approaching here suggests that the new
joy boy might have officially arrived
since we had plenty of evidence that
luffy is the new joy boy it's pretty
likely that zunisha might sense this now
and is coming to help the new joy boy
just as it helped the old one this could
be an important detail for how the straw
hats manage to escape from this
seemingly inescapable situation but let
me know your thoughts on this is this
yet another clue that luffy is joyboy or
do you have another theory as to what
momo's words could mean who was your mvp
for me it pretty much just carried over
from the last chapter i sort of feel
like these chapters were very related
because of the big mom and kid in law
fight and yeah kid and law continued to
be awesome and get the job done i also
really enjoyed seeing big mom's
frustration and her thoughts directed to
roger clearly she's not confident
anymore in her own powers and she is
really bothered by these new brats who
seem to keep coming and keep gaining
power as she's getting older and older
and further and further from her prime
but yeah that is it for this one if you
did enjoy it and want to keep the
reviews coming you know what to do
channel the pirating within and smash
that like button with no mercy always
remember smashing that like button is
piraking energy and passing is scared
orochi energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this video subscribe and
hit that notification bell too you
guessed it turn on all notifications or
you will miss future one piece videos
and updates and while you wait for the
next video to drop feel free to check
out my big one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords supernova admirals every fruit
and much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys